cette nouvelle édition entièrement
consacré à cette guerre en ukraine
cinquième jour donc de l'offensive russe
dans le pays l'ukraine qui affirment ce
matin que moscou a ralenti le rythme de
l'offensive alors que des pourparlers
doivent se tenir à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie dans la
région de tchernobyl est la délégation
ukrainienne est arrivée sur place elle
devrait relayer la position de la
présidence ukrainienne qui demande un
cessez le feu immédiat et le retrait des
forces russes d'ukraine est les
autorités biélorusses affirme prête à
les accueillir le ministère biélorusse
des affaires étrangères a publié une
photo sur facebook montrant la salle des
pourparlers alors avant de parler
précisément de la situation sur le
terrain on va retrouver pierre marescaux
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes français d'origine ukrainienne
et vous avez fui kiev vous vous trouvez
maintenant en pologne comment s'est
passé votre départ de kiev
bonjour alors mon départ de kiev c'est
évidemment passer de manière très
précipitée je dois dire que on avait on
n'avait pas du tout imaginé ce qui ce
qui s'est passé là ces derniers jours
donc nous ma femme et moi avions dans le
nord de kiev donc dans une zone où des
combats très importants ont eu lieu
entre les la résistance ukrainienne et
les forces russes nous sommes partis il
y a trois jours après avoir passé une
nuit une première nuit dans un abri
antibombes installés dans le métro à la
station de métro à côté de notre
domicile nous sommes partis très
précipitamment lorsque les tanks russes
arrivés littéralement sous nos fenêtres
dans notre quartier donc nos avions
heureusement une voiture avec laquelle
nous avons fui la capitale pour nous
mettre à l'abri le plus à l'ouest
possible il faut savoir que moi je
n'étais pas parti pour pour fuir au
départ je suis reparti pour mettre
d'abord ma femme à l'abri qui est
enceinte de neuf mois et nous avons donc
rouler vers l'ouest nous avons passé les
différents blocs poste des checkpoints
nous avons
commandé rage roulait quasiment soûles
et sous les bombardements et nous sommes
aujourd'hui arrivés après un périple de
plus de 2
50 ou 60 heures en pologne la tente
évidemment à la frontière polonaise a
été extrêmement longue nous sommes
retrouvés avec un flot de réfugiés
ukrainien qui arrivait par par dizaines
de milliers et donc nous avons dû passer
effectivement plus de 30 à 40 heures
dans notre dans notre voiture j'ai envie
de vous demander comment va votre femme
après cette fuite bien sûr à neuf mois
de grossesse on imagine le choc et et la
fatigue d'un tel périple vers vers la
pologne
alors écoutez effectivement ma femme est
extrêmement fatiguée elle est exténué
elle et elle et elle est allée assez
assez faible au delà du de la difficulté
physique quand on est enceinte de de
voyager comme ça et de et de comment
diriger effectivement de tout le stress
que cela implique il y à aussi
aujourd'hui l'aspect psychologique à
régler puisqu'on vient tout juste de
prendre conscience de ce qui s'est passé
je pense et du fait que aujourd'hui
nous avons tout laissé absolument
dernièrement on imagine cet état de
sidération
pouvez vous nous décrire ce que vous
avez vu lors de cet exode on a vu des
images avec des milliers et des milliers
d'ukrainiens prenant prenant la fuite
avec des heures et des heures
d'embouteillages
voilà alors lorsque nous arrivons
lorsque nous sommes arrivés à la près du
poste frontière côté ukrainien nous
étions encore à 11 à 12 kilomètres du
poste frontière effectivement il y a des
autour de ces postes frontières donc là
où on était très exactement il a vu
lille dans laquelle tous les réfugiés
arrivent avant de se mettre dans la file
pour
attendre leur tour
attendre attendre de passer et là
effectivement dans la file c'est
terrible vous avez essentiellement des
femmes et des enfants puisque les hommes
ont été mobilisés pour combattre
l'invasion russe chez eux donc sur le
terrain et vous avez essentiellement des
familles avec beaucoup d'enfants
d'aider des gens dans des situations
vraiment de difficultés très importantes
mois juste avant qu'on passe aux postes
frontières ukrainiens des mères de
famille sont venus me demander de
prendre leurs enfants avec elle
puisqu'elle n'avait pas les moyens de
partir avec eux et de les emmener
quelque part en sécurité en pologne
enfin y est vraiment des situations de
détresse incroyable et heureusement côté
ukrainien les gens se sont organisées il
ya des choses qui sont mis en place mise
en place des distributions de nourriture
d'eau de vivre de manière à aider ces
gens qui vont passer en moyenne
plus de
50 heures à la frontière y en a on voit
ces images pendant que vous nous parliez
de cet élan de solidarité
bien sûr qui s'est formée pour aider
tous et tous ces réfugiés s'est déplacée
j'ai envie de vous poser une dernière
question par pierre marescaux où
vivez-vous maintenant et qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour vous
écoutez alors j'ai de la chance d'avoir
une partie de ma famille donc des
cousins en pologne donc ici à radom donc
pour l'instant nous sommes nous sommes
hébergés chez eux donc ma femme - et une
partie de ma belle famille puisque j'ai
pris ma la sors de ma femme et la mère
de ma femme aussi avec avec nous pour
les mettre en sécurité écoutez pour
l'instant je ne sais absolument pas ce
qui va se passer pour nous j'aimerais
pour ma part le plus vite possible après
la naissance de ma fille retourner en
ukraine pour aider les ukrainiens à
reconstruire leur leur leur pays qui est
aussi le nôtre en réalité et j'aimerais
effectivement
organiser quelque chose pour pour pour
aider ces gens qui sont restés sur place
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
pierre marescaux et beaucoup de courage
à vous bien sûr merci